Yeah.
Mama was drunk most of the year.
God,
no,
it ain't right.
And then
let them money.
Wayne
goes
by,
okay,
have your medicine,
can't get no child.
Kid.
Ah,
Wayne
goes on and
on and on.
Okay.
How are we an do you know?
Mm.
So,
so,
so the imagery and that is,
is,
is sort of a walkthrough,
um,
to an extent the,
the,
the parts of the world that,
that I was in,
um,
in the putting together of this book.
Um,
and that those parts of the world,
we're also historical as well as geographical.
Um,
the last book I wrote,
all the president's bankers was very much,
um,
historical.
It went through the last century and a bit of the relationship of presidents in
both parties and the bankers and just sort of what the actual personal
relationships were and how they were interacting before various types of world
events,
wars policies and so forth.
And this was kind of that.
But from just the 10 years since the financial crisis of 2008,
um,
and in rather going back to the history of one country,
I sort of expanded it to what's happening globally since the financial crisis.
Um,
and to get to the punchline first,
because I also want you to feel like you can interrupt me and ask questions.
I know I'm here to speak to you.
Um,
but you're,
you know,
sort of a very informed group.
And so I think that if I say something that's either troubling or confusing or
you want me to expand or whatever it might be just,
you know,
shout out cause I think that that will be a good thing.
Um,
but anyways,
so I,
I divide my book into the regions of,
of the world that were either involved in or affected or impacted by the
financial crisis and then sort of how they've acted differently since then.
And I talk about collusion.
It's not about Russia,
it's not about politics.
Um,
well everything is ultimately about money in politics.
But that's not the point of the book.
The point of the book is to look at what the main central banks in the world
have done in a sort of unprecedented way since the financial crisis,
to artificially kind of stimulate the financial system,
the banks,
and subsequently the markets.
Um,
in a way that's been very,
um,
historically epic in terms of size,
but also in terms of just their unlimited capabilities in terms of the amounts
that they've created in terms of not being able to know auditing.
No,
no sort of information going in and out as to where that money actually goes.
Um,
and so what I did was I didn't have a chapter on the Federal Reserve,
which I'll talk about in a bit more in a second,
which is kind of the central character.
Um,
if we look at central banks is just sort of characters the world and the
individuals that run them as just the characters that are part of those scenes.
Um,
I took 2008 is the beginning of each chapter in each region and I always started
there and then looked at how that region was impacted.
So I go to Mexico,
to Brazil,
to China,
to Japan and throughout Europe.
And each time I sort of go back to the beginning and say,
okay,
well this is the perspective of what happened between the Federal Reserve,
the United States in this area.
Um,
and this is how the fallout,
um,
occurred or this is how they expanded but not really.
Um,
and my general theme is that having had an unprecedented amount of money being
thrown into the system,
sort of fabricated or manufacturer or are conjured by the central banks has
really distorted,
um,
the idea of value.
It's,
it's even distorted the idea of where I'll companies who actually,
um,
you know,
sort of show their profits and losses based on actual cash,
um,
actual revenues and so forth that aren't artificially stimulated by money coming
in from an outside source are,
are sort of operating in a world in which they're also ones that are.
And so in terms of just the graph of that,
I wasn't again going to do slides cause I tend to,
um,
I can just write on this.
Um,
so the,
so the way that looks and if anyone wants me to just mention what a central bank
is,
well,
making sure of these,
right.
Um,
does everybody know what a central bank is?
Okay.
So,
so,
so basically the central bank and the Fed in particular here,
um,
was designed,
usually designed to provide emergency capital in the event that the financial
system can produce it for itself.
It's going to create a bigger crisis for the rest of the economy.
There needs to be,
um,
a particular reaction to say a war or like,
you know,
interplanetary aliens coming or something like that.
And that the,
the,
the reality is that they have clauses in their mandates that are emergency
clauses to be able to do this.
So it's all quite legal.
Um,
and I'm not advocating that the collusion of central banks is something that's
illegal.
I do get asked that question,
but it is something that's to an extent deceitful,
um,
because by having a large supply of artificial money that has no limitation in
terms of when and how it can be fabricated as it has been the last 10 years,
it,
that distortion thing,
um,
does create a level of deceit.
So one of the things that happened since the financial crisis,
I'm bad at drawing but I'm just going to,
this is 2008 and this is now and um,
I have this on my Twitter,
uh,
this,
this particular graph,
but I thought it was cool because it was three lines.
Um,
one was the Federal Reserve and how much money when it dumped it into the
system.
Um,
one is the Central Bank of Japan and one is the European Central Bank because
the idea of this collusion is that the major countries,
central banks have also adopted a cheap money policy and a quantitative easing
or buying securities policy,
buying bonds,
buying ETFs are buying stocks if you're in Japan by corporate bonds,
if you're in Europe where they've been able to fabricate money and,
and decide where effectively they want to invest it,
but they'd go through a financial system and that has an impact on the market.
So the Fed kind of started this 2008 and,
and,
and sort of,
they did some sort of a taper in terms of this,
this line represents the amount of money they conjured since the 2008 period to
buy.
Um,
in the case of the United States treasury bonds,
government bonds and mortgage bonds from,
from the paging system.
Um,
and so this is kind of 2015
and though they haven't,
this isn't really,
only has a tiny line down.
Um,
no,
they haven't continued here.
Um,
they did,
they have a pretty high value,
four and a half trillion dollars of what I consider to be subsidies for the
banking system in the market because they're really coming out of the sort of
the electronic,
um,
uh,
activities of the Fed.
So this is the Fed line.
Colors don't mean anything by the way.
I'm just randomly picking colors.
Um,
then the European central bank kind of came in and did something similar except
that they were kind of here and then they kind of did that.
Right.
So this is the European Central Bank.
Um,
this is kind of 2012 where my,
my bad geometrics is such that they kind of accelerated their process of being
involved in quantitative easing,
um,
by a lot when there was a credit crisis in Europe.
So the minute there wasn't enough money in Europe,
they thought they had recovered.
They really hadn't.
They were still adopting the policy are colluding with the Fed to produce money
in the system.
They,
uh,
they kind of accelerated.
And in this period of time where the,
the Fed sort of stopped putting as much in,
they've accelerated even further.
So now they're around that five and a half trillion.
And then the Bank of Japan,
which was the bank that actually created quantitative easing to begin with,
they came up in 2001 of this idea that if they produced money into the system,
because they're banks were basically,
uh,
undergoing a collapse in the beginning of the two thousands that they would have
a way to,
to help them.
And they did produce money.
They did engage in quantitative easing because it's really,
really tiny.
So I talk about in my Japan chapter how Ben Bernanki,
who was the chair of the Fed when all this kind of started,
um,
goes in front of Congress and talks about how what we're doing is not what the
Japanese are doing.
It's really different.
Um,
we're doing it for other purposes,
but the reality is that the mechanisms are the same.
They're producing,
um,
money in order to increase the money supply in order to then decide where it
goes into the banking system,
into corporations who then borrow it,
which then goes into the stock market or other,
other financial assets.
So,
so the Bank of Japan was kind of also,
I'm here and then in about 2013 they did that.
So
really right,
they did that.
So there are around it like 5 trillion right now.
MMM.
And basically the reason they sort of had an acceleration in about 2013,
2014 is because from an economic perspective,
having watched all of this happen,
um,
the prime minister of the,
the,
the head of Japan,
Shinzo lobby decided that we should be doing the same thing or being,
doing more so that in Japan.
And so the head of the central bank now in Japan,
Kuroda,
this is Mario Draghi
currently this now at the Fed,
you know,
through different periods is Jerome Powell.
But there's been three different,
uh,
fed heads,
two different Japanese heads and,
and two different European heads over this time period.
Um,
they've all kind of engaged in the same process.
And as a result,
there was about,
mmm,
well this is 15 trillion.
But when you,
when you aggregate all of these numbers and you aggregate all of this graph,
the level of money that's continuing to be crop conjured and dumped into the
system is going up.
So when you hear in the news that the Fed is tapering,
that they're,
that they're doing this and that somehow as a reflection of their experiments
and quantitative easing and cheap money succeeding,
you have to understand,
and this is the,
the collusive efforts involved,
that collectively the world is,
is increasing their amount of quantitative easing.
It's just happening in different countries for different reasons.
And in the European Central Bank realm,
it's being dumped into corporates.
For the most part,
in Japan,
it's a combination of government bonds and stocks.
And in the U S it's kind of stopped.
It was a combination of government bonds and mortgage bonds.
So it was always going into the place that needed the most help.
But,
but the say corporations in the,
in,
in Europe that needed that help,
um,
we're receiving it basically without giving very much in return.
The European Central Bank would decide,
well,
we're going to give money to this particular company in Germany versus these
particular companies in Greece.
And that was a,
that was in a lot of ways a political decision,
but the monetary elements of that,
um,
enabled certain countries and certain companies and certain stocks to go higher
simply because there was an outside artificial source,
um,
to,
to push things higher.
And so when I started going around the world and sort of examining what,
what the real actors were doing throughout this period,
this is just kind of the summary and the summary again,
looks like this,
uh,
right from like a half a trillion.
MMM.
There's a picture that starts to be developed and that's that the,
the ones that had the ability to produce money,
did their markets have risen more substantially?
There has been more sort of speculation outside of those markets because once
they go up,
where else do you go?
Capital flows out.
It goes to Mexico scope.
And so forth.
But in those of countries,
there's less than an ability and they didn't choose necessarily to get involved
in quantitative easing.
So there was an entire sort of political ramification that doesn't really get
discussed behind just the value of money and the amount of quantitative easing
that these major central banks are doing that actually has changed kind of the
shape of the world.
Um,
so the first country I go to in collusion is actually Mexico.
and,
and the reason I did that,
so I spent a lot of time working with companies in Mexico and stuff.
Um,
but that basically the Mexican government and the individuals who were really
involved in the period from the 2008 to 2018 that were running the central bank
in Mexico had real strong opinions about what the Fed was doing.
And a lot of countries had strong opinions about the Fed was doing it because to
an extent,
it's just not fair.
It's not really capitalism,
it's not really free markets.
It's kind of like,
you know,
a subsidy for the financial system that then has major ramifications of creating
an artificial system.
And that can go terribly wrong very quickly.
Um,
if it gets taken away,
which is why it's not being taken away and there's ramifications to that.
So what Mexico decided in 2008 and their economy is actually doing fine.
Um,
the crisis happens north of the border in the beginning.
They say,
well,
it doesn't really affect us.
It's a financial crisis is contained in the bank's feds taking care of it.
But then it starts to become apparent very,
very quickly that that's not the case.
That if there's a recession in the states or if there's a depression in the
states or the financing closes up and there's no credit going throughout the
system,
it impacts everyone.
So the head of the Central Bank of Mexico,
a guy named [inaudible],
he went to Washington,
is part of the establishment needs,
sort of floated in the sort of economic ideas of the Fed governors and so forth.
It goes up to Washington and he says to Ben Bernanki,
look,
we've,
we've seen this movie,
we know how it ends.
It doesn't end well.
We have the Tequila crisis.
In 94,
we restructured our banking system.
Smaller banks got eaten up,
people got thrown out of jobs,
companies close.
It took us a really long time to recover.
And more than just the economic problems of recovery are people lost confidence
in the system.
And they are that that manifested in,
in lots of crowds in the streets.
But the point was,
um,
if you simply create money to simply help the financial system to help the
banks,
it's,
it's not really stable capital.
It's not really ultimately going to work.
Um,
there will be bubbles,
there will be problems.
And Ben Bernanki says thanks.
Doesn't cover or tease in his memoirs at all.
Um,
even though this meeting was covered by the Wall Street Journal was public and
he basically goes about and sort of manufacturing this,
this,
uh,
emergency quantitative easing mount,
and then has the whole world join it.
Why does a whole world join in?
Or why did the major countries join into any quantitative easing movement?
Um,
because if you have capital in the u s and money's made very cheap,
so it's,
it's more liquid to the financial system so they can so sort out the stuff they
did.
Um,
and rates are higher elsewhere in particular in the main countries in which
there's with which there's trade or with which the banks have relationships,
then the money's going to leave.
And so the only way to sort of keep the dollar strong enough and keep the money
in the u s is to have the export,
the same method to the countries that have the largest relationships.
So something like Mexico has to also deal with its own economy.
So if it reduces rates by too much,
that will cause inflation in the economy because it's,
it has a more direct impact on actual people in,
on actual prices because it's a smaller economy to begin with.
Um,
and it's reliant on other economies for its trade,
buy,
buy more so,
so,
or tears didn't want to reduce rates like the Fed was doing very quickly and
they couldn't produce money electronically to buy securities in Mexico.
They didn't have the same capacity.
Um,
and so they didn't,
so he didn't,
he went about criticizing the u s as a result,
he sort of lost his job or he didn't get reappointed to be the head of the
Central Bank of Mexico and the subsequent appointee.
I'm Amanda,
I'm Augustine Carstons who,
um,
also sort of was in the same group as the people running the Fed treasury
department and so forth came in and he at first said,
okay,
I'll do what the Fed's going to do a reduce rates.
I'll keep it sort of stable between the border of Mexico and the U s I'll follow
along.
He used to go public about the fact that this evening was going to help the real
economy ultimately will trickle out of the banking system and out of the markets
and it'll help sort of real growth and longterm growth in wages and everything
else.
Um,
and that's what he said originally.
That's Kinda how he,
he got that job and have that Jeff for a while in this period.
But,
but the reality was they didn't do that and he started feeling the political
pressure in Mexico of the fact that Mexico wasn't really getting any of this
money into their economy and it was very,
very obvious.
Um,
and so he started criticizing the Fed and everything else and he ultimately
resigned before the end of his term last year.
And he's now the head of the Bank of international settlements,
which is the Central Bank of central banks that does reporting and all of these
activities and always used to support the Fed,
the IMF,
the World Bank,
the ECB when it came into being as doing the right thing by their economies,
by employment versus inflation,
which is one of their mandates by helping their system.
And it was created basically as a sort of unified u s Europe kind of entity to
begin with.
It's starting to have real critiques and the fact that it is now run by someone
who bought then kind of sold the policy of the United States and is now at the
head of that institution really shows a shift in general in the world in terms
of how it looks at what the end game of this could be,
how risky it could be for the rest of the world.
Um,
and it's just simply questioning how long this can go on.
so that's been one shift and other shift.
It's a longer story I won't get into it is in Brazil because that has,
it's,
it's so many of its own sort of pieces of corruption and scandals and government
overthrows and so forth.
But one of the people who's currently running for the presidency of Brazil,
um,
as a man named Rick Murray Alyth,
I pronounced it because for some reason my Portuguese is very bad.
I was,
I was corrected last night actually in Berkeley about my pronunciation of his
name,
but he was someone who was head of the Central Bank of Brazil when this all
started,
when,
when the crisis all started happening,
um,
and he,
and the president of Brazil at the time,
a Lula who is now in jail,
was,
um,
at first saying,
Brazil's not going to be impacted by the crisis,
same way Mexico said it wasn't going to be until they were very shortly
thereafter.
Um,
and he wanted to do with the u s want was doing,
um,
the party in power who became empower the Workers Party,
uh,
headed by a woman named Dilma.
Rousseff said,
no,
we want to maintain help for Brazil.
Um,
he says,
we want to do with the u s that he'd lose it.
He doesn't get,
he doesn't get appointed to be the central bank.
Later he goes back into the private sector,
he winds up being the minister of Finance,
um,
when her government was overthrown.
And so he's basically gone from being a central banker,
uh,
to private sector to being a minister of finance.
And now he's running for president in the meantime,
Brazil,
uh,
during that period,
and this is just where politics meets monetary policy has basically reduced its
rates from,
this is a completely separate graph.
This doesn't count on that graph.
They reduce their rates from 14 and a half percent to six and a half percent.
Um,
in a very short period of time.
Mexico has raised its rates from three and a half percent
to seven and a half percent in the last few years as well.
So they've gone independent of the Fed,
they've gone sort of dependent on the Fed.
Um,
and,
and that really manifests into political relationships if you're an investor.
It actually also manifests into figuring out why this has happened because it's
very unique that actually Mexico as higher,
uh,
rates then,
then Brazil.
Um,
so,
so there was a lot of shakeout as well,
photo,
a monetary policy perspective where government bonds are trading,
where stocks are trading and,
and who shifting in the sort of power relationships of,
of central banks.
And also the government is now central banks is supposed to be independent of
governments.
That's how they are mandated.
So supposedly the Federal Reserve is independent of whatever the u s government
wants to do.
The Bank of Japan is,
is independent.
Um,
and there's a lot of,
I went through a lot of documentation.
I have this team of researchers around the world who new languages that I didn't
know.
And so we're,
we're,
we're looking at real sort of,
um,
media and publications at the time,
real documents and research information that was coming from the central banks
themselves.
Um,
and,
and it was interesting to me was a lot of,
um,
both criticism of what was happening on the outside and trying to figure out if
they should adopt it on the inside.
Um,
which is part of where,
um,
where there's a lot of tension and still tension in the world.
Um,
but China,
which is the middle of the book,
is a place that has grown in its super powerness from an economic perspective
and also its relationships with other countries.
And one of the reasons it doesn't get talked about,
um,
is that it shows to criticize very vocally,
the monetary policy,
the United States,
um,
because of this,
this whole creation of money policy.
Now it has created money as well,
but it chooses to do it outside of sort of the main g seven groups.
Um,
and it does it for different purposes and you'd probably know this here.
I mean it does it for building infrastructure,
for prepaying for technology and R and D and individuals and also for trade
alliances with other countries in that region with Mexico,
with Brazil,
in order to establish itself as,
as a sort of more,
um,
both from a trade perspective and a monetary perspective.
Um,
superpower.
The reason that all started to happen in 2008 2009 is because it had essentially
the central bank in China that at the People's Bank of China,
um,
got very public with his criticism of the Fed.
Ultimately the Chinese currency,
the Ren was accepted into the IMF special drawing rights basket,
which is the sort of representation of the main currencies that had always been
the dollar and the euro,
which had before that been the German mark and the French franc,
um,
and the Japanese yen and the British pound.
And in,
in,
in this period of time,
the Chinese currency,
the renting became part of this basket because even the IMF that had been
established to really work on the reserve currencies of the dollar and the euro
mainly,
um,
was beginning to criticize whether all this money being dumped in the system
when it is retracted or when rates rise or when something goes wrong with all
the debt that's been created on the back of it,
um,
causes problems throughout the developing world.
Root causes problems within the U S so they've been very critical of late as
well.
Um,
but China has been able to utilize that,
um,
in order to really become and create more trade agreements and more currency
arrangements,
um,
and also develop their,
their alliances in their own companies within China.
That's what they've been doing with that money.
We really haven't been,
we've been,
I'm just,
just as a sort of super power,
this money,
it's predominantly gone into financial speculation into the markets that hasn't
been dedicated to,
um,
instead of building a railway or,
or building a canal or,
or,
or anything like that or lending to other countries in order for them to be able
to do that because they're partners and that strengthens them.
Therefore,
the trade relationship,
we,
we've really gone sort of off the rails relative to that.
That's not to say China doesn't have problems,
it's just to say that,
um,
in this period of time,
money's been created here and in Europe and in Japan for an and to a lesser
extent,
um,
in the UK for different reason.
And that reason has been more of a financial reason and not so much as a long
term economic stability,
a reason as it has an Asia.
I talked a little bit about Europe and,
um,
I was sort of the last chapter of the book,
but one of the man of,
one of the things that's come out of the CBS policy,
um,
aside from the fact that there was criticism from certain countries like Germany
against the CB,
because they're like,
our country is fine.
We have savers,
we're developing,
we don't need this whole easing thing.
We don't want to be concerned about bubbles bursting.
Um,
is that the sort of southern part of Europe,
Greece,
Italy,
Spain,
and so forth happened how the benefits,
um,
of the same amount of money being put in.
So when there's a lot of money that's put in in one part of the market and it's
not sort of divided or,
or,
or even selected or chosen to be putting other parts of the market,
it creates inequalities and volatility and instability.
So what we've seen in the last few months in,
and even our stock market is,
is the sort of beginning of
more volatility coming into the market,
more sort of default and delinquencies coming into some of the corporate bonds
that were,
um,
issue because money was so cheap and therefore repaying the debt was so low.
Um,
but the debt payments we'll get higher.
and also money coming out of the stock market to make debt payments and then
separately buy backs,
which,
which keep the level of the market up.
So you have these two sort of competing forces of capital,
um,
that are creating more volatility.
Now you have cheap money still available.
Um,
you have a lot of buy back,
some,
some from companies that have cash and some from companies that have received
cash.
Um,
but nonetheless,
and then you also have cracks in the system from both the rumors that are in the
market as to whether or not this can stop anytime any of these central bank
leaders talk about the possibility of it stopping the markets tend to get
really,
really upset.
And then the next meeting there's like,
oh,
we didn't really mean it.
There isn't really inflation.
There's a really growth,
we're going to stop.
Um,
which is what he does a lot.
I mean,
they all do it,
but,
um,
it,
it's interesting because even even the Japanese,
um,
last week had a meeting the Bank of Japan and they came out and they said,
well,
we're going to probably have to keep doing this like forever.
Um,
they use the term unlimited.
Uh,
Mario Draghi said the same thing.
Um,
the week and a half ago when the European Central Bank came out and said,
yes,
we're keeping rates at negative.
Um,
and we're also going to continue our quantitative easing programs.
So these lines up the Fed is kind of,
yes,
it's a big question.
That limit,
is there really an alternative to printing all this money?
Because if you look at the rate of debt creation over the past 30,
almost 40 years,
you know,
debt growth has exceeded GDP growth almost that entire time through our
projections that somebody,
public pensions will be insolvent.
That there's no like,
mathematical way to make that possible.
So is is unlimited money printing just the easiest way to kind of like softly
default on that rather than causing some catastrophic collapse?
Yeah,
well we're all pushing in the,
or having to worry about a solution to it.
I mean,
yes,
that has increased over the last 30,
40 years relative to GDP,
but it's,
it's accelerated by a lot.
It's increased because it's,
it's had this sort of plaster over.
So if the system which kind of started this,
this,
um,
in,
in 2008 was on the brink of,
of what it said to be collapsed,
there are different ways that that could have been addressed.
One way would have been to let one or two extra banks collapsed and that really
sounded harsh at the time.
Um,
but you know,
throughout Wall Street banks have collapsed.
I mean,
it's,
it's not like that that hadn't happened and the problem was there was so much
attention focused on whether that was going to create a massive depression going
forward that there was no conversation or very limited conversation in
Washington as to doing something else.
Um,
I'm sure very Matthew that the reality,
I'll just go back for like one little explanation of,
of how I saw that was at the time of the 2008 financial crisis.
Um,
there was,
um,
which was predicated on a mortgage bonds and all the derivatives associated with
them and all the credit and insurance that was traded between banks and all
that.
Um,
there was only like a half a trillion dollars worth of upset subprime mortgages
in the market at the time and half a trillion,
right?
Um,
there was $14 trillion worth of toxic assets of acids that we're reliant on
those sub prime mortgages paying their interest and if they didn't get paid,
would start to deteriorate in value.
Banks lent to investors around the world,
including pension funds and clear helped pension funds,
including,
you know,
municipalities,
corporations,
other financial entities,
uh,
10 times that.
So $140 trillion effectively was on offer going after a half a trillion dollars
of subprime related assets.
So that problem is what causes an acceleration of the production of artificial
capital.
Um,
in order to solve what was really a major financial crisis it was,
but what could have been done as you could have just paid off a half a trillion
dollars worth of subprime mortgages and,
and forget whether that's an ideology of you're paying people who didn't deserve
it or bags.
And it doesn't matter that the economics of it would have been far,
far cheaper.
Instead,
the decision was made to plaster over that and to start this creation of 0%
money so that banks would have the liquidity to start to re whoever was still
left standing to repay each other so that companies could repay off,
send the money they had borrowed that were still left standing,
um,
that were involved in this.
And as a result,
um,
it has created an extra level of capital in the system that makes,
debt accelerate and also makes stock levels go up artificially.
Um,
so that the next time there's a crisis,
you're falling from a much higher height.
So absolutely they want that not to happen,
which is why every single time a fed chair says there's growth,
there's inflation.
This is like you can train this.
I mean if you're just even looking at this from an investment perspective,
um,
it's going to be followed by some major hiccup in the market and then some other
central bank or maybe the same one or someone in their country saying,
well,
no,
we didn't mean it.
And that's exactly what the European Central Bank was talking about growth a
minute ago.
So was the,
the Bank of England,
they were going to be raising rates.
All these rumors in the market,
it put the pound up into,
you know,
Brexit's fine.
It's all,
it's all going to be worked out.
The central banks is going to raise rates.
It's a sign of strength.
It's going to help our currency into negotiations with Europe.
There's all these sort of discussions and,
and,
and the media narratives and politics going on back and forth.
Reality is they don't have the growth in the central bank head last week said,
by the way,
or things aren't so great.
Um,
they did not,
well,
they can raise rates on Thursday.
They're not going to,
I think,
um,
because actually the numbers don't bear them out.
And also it,
it hurt the market.
And so yes,
you are right.
Long answer to your question,
but the reality is they want to keep this going.
They found a method to do it.
And that just means that when things crack the crack from a much higher height
than they would have or even did,
um,
during 2008,
so now we have four point 5 trillion in the market as money supply extra.
Exactly.
It wasn't me.
How come inflation hasn't happened because all this money or in the bags,
it's such a good question.
And,
and different people ask that in different settings for different reasons.
And it,
I think that inflation has not risen on the sort of average generic way that
inflation is considered and calculated because this money has inflated markets.
It,
this is inflation,
the,
the level of,
well,
a third graph would,
well this and,
and sort of the stock market.
Yeah.
Um,
so it's kind of dipped a little bit,
but it's sort of like that.
And you'd have QE one,
QE two,
QE three,
you know,
Europe,
Japan,
and so forth.
Um,
that,
that ultimately this 15,000,000,000,020 1 trillion if you had,
and all the other banks that are involved
and the market level
pretty much the same.
So there has been a tremendous amount of inflation.
There's been inflation.
The money supply that has gone into inflation of financial assets gone into
lining new debt.
It's gone onto inflating the value of stock because it's been a artificial
source of money that's been used not just for stock buybacks cause that's kind
of a one to one relationship.
But,
but all along the way it's been there as a sort of security blanket,
um,
for banks to be able to leverage more companies are leveraging more.
Right now actually they're on average,
um,
companies in the s and P or leveraged more than they were before the financial
crisis.
So there was inflation,
but it's not inflation of real prices where it had been for a while,
for example in Mexico where they were reducing rates,
it was inflating real prices because the relationship of central bank and that
monetary policy was more closely connected to the real economy and the fact that
we don't have inflation in,
in these countries because we don't,
um,
officially,
but we have inflation in financial assets is a fine of how,
just sort of off the rails this,
this,
this has gone.
And my second question quickly,
um,
but also we used to have the goal centered,
which would basically be something we could peg,
right?
The actual value of a dollar to today we don't have that.
We also have petrodollars what's you're representing kind of an acid or a
resource that can be traded.
Is that also why the dollar is still strong and we haven't lost the value of the
dollar in the market or is that completely unrelated to,
it's not entirely annoyed that the concept of the gold standard,
um,
was something or has it been something not returning to it exactly as it was pre
71 but,
but,
but returning to some sort of component of goals,
say in the special drawing rights basket.
So you have your five currencies and,
and you have gold and they're sort of an average,
so you have something that's a real asset or,
or some sort of manner bringing back a version of the gold standard gets
discussed.
But for example,
when the Chinese,
a Chinese central bank was,
was criticizing the Fed policy of just sort of inflating a sort of currency but,
but not having anything real behind it to back it.
Um,
Ben Bernanke,
he actually went on the defensive and,
um,
I have this in,
in,
in different parts of the book throughout the years and started talking about
how we,
we don't want to gold standard.
Like it wasn't even brought up as a topic when he started defending it.
And one of the reasons are just throwing it away as,
as,
as a potential.
And one of the reasons for that is you can't create gold.
Um,
this is not to say that,
that we should be on a full gold standard or that it's,
it's,
it's actually a practical development.
But having gold as a portion of,
of a currency basket makes some sense because it's,
it's just an anchor.
Um,
it's,
it's just something that's,
it's actually physically there and it's physically,
um,
it doesn't retain the same kind of value.
The more there's other currencies,
and this is more speculation in the market that it might've,
if everything was going off of real trade and real hard acid,
um,
but,
but it had that had an anchor level to it.
And,
and the fact that it isn't a part of the main system,
but it is something that gets bought up by some of the countries,
the emerging countries that are trying to trade with each other their own
currencies as well as to try to have more of a portion of gold reserves in the
potential that they create some sort of standard amongst themselves or something
outside of the dollar,
outside of the euro.
Um,
it's certainly something that
has kind of been reinitiated in,
in this whole process,
like where that goes and how long it takes to get there.
Um,
I don't know.
I mean there's,
there's people out there,
so the dollars going into flight tomorrow and I'm gold's going to go sky high.
I mean,
I think there's a trend to gold being considered as something that should
anchor,
um,
this,
but,
and,
and other countries using their currencies and trading with each other like
China and Russia,
like Europe and Japan.
There's a lot of trade agreements that have been developed and,
and I,
I have a lot of them in,
in,
in collusion,
but that had been developed in these years amongst countries,
um,
to try and offset some of the potential risk of really this policy,
not,
not simply the dollar geopolitically,
but really the policy of,
of sort of bolstering a system that's not really restructured and that has the
potential to bring down,
uh,
an economy or a multiple economies.
Again,
I'm one alternative that that comes up in questions is crypto currencies.
Um,
and for,
for similar reasons.
And,
and what's interesting is that though there's a lot of volatility in bitcoin and
other currencies,
um,
and,
and there's a lot of risk in being involved in,
there's diff speculating in them,
which has its own risk attached,
but there's actually,
if you're going to use them on a regular basis,
um,
that kind of volatility could,
you know,
ruin anyone's business on any given day or pop it up.
And that's not the kind of volatility in the real economy the most people can,
um,
can or should handle.
Um,
but the idea of having alternative any alternatives to this system,
um,
is very much an accelerated concept because of,
of,
of how it's been handled because nothing has really been reformed or fixed.
It's just been plastered over by,
by sort of this artificial a part of the system.
So,
okay.
The head of the IMF,
Christine La Garde,
who again IMF,
the International Monetary Fund,
very much a part of the system,
very much involved in the whole dollar European currency system from when it was
created in the wake of World War II.
And it was created to basically subsidize countries that were allies of the U S
and Europe.
And this is kind of part of the point.
She currently has been on multiple
public arenas talking about alternative currencies and how cryptocurrencies is
something that is happening and it's expanding and they need to be aware of it.
Um,
there are full swat teams of the Federal Reserve now that are doing that sort of
under the radar.
And there's also,
you know,
you can get jobs at the European Central Bank right now that are listed to be
involved in developing,
um,
you know,
technology related to,
to cryptocurrency analysis and so forth right now.
So,
um,
they're,
they're definitely all involved from a different perspective,
but the idea that it sort of,
um,
yeah,
who actually ultimately gets the sort of regulation of it versus the use of it.
Um,
I think it's still up for grabs because
yeah,
if you had cryptos created by the same central banks that are creating this
currency,
um,
then you don't necessarily gain
sort of autonomy from the system by doing that.
But if,
but if there are cryptos that are regulated by a portion of this so that they're
not as sort of volatile for end users and they actually might have,
um,
might spread that much more quickly.
Followup question to that.
I've kind of just as a Dabbler in cryptocurrency,
you know,
people always ask,
well,
what does it based on?
And the answer is,
well,
not,
not much,
but it does have a fixed supply.
Think it was just the original Bitcoin,
like 21 million coins.
Well,
gold is a fixed supply.
So when I look at those,
I think I'm,
one of the arguments is uh,
well sure,
you know,
bitcoin is volatile,
but if nobody's on the gold standard,
it doesn't matter either.
It's kind of an odd,
magical thing to me of how people decide to buy into,
um,
agreeing to,
uh,
stick with a fixed supply of anything.
When it comes to,
I guess I would say a game this big,
what would be the,
the motive?
Would it just be looking for something stable and,
and what would,
what would bring would bring this air balloon back down,
I guess?
Well,
I think the idea,
um,
and it's slightly different.
I mean that's,
the language for Crypto is similar to the language for four goals and that's,
that's not an accident.
And the idea of having a fixed supply as,
as part of what sort of pegs it to some form of anchor,
right,
is it is not an accident either.
With respect to gold,
it doesn't mean that you can't have speculation and golden and tell if you were
had a gold standard or a similar thing to go,
Sandy,
you can still speculation.
You could still have stockpiles of gold,
you can still sort of squeeze the market,
et Cetera.
But,
but the idea of anything outside of the system is that it is fixed and it,
it does have a limitation in this process has been particularly unlimited.
I mean,
it,
it's still going up.
Um,
and so even though the Fed can say,
talk about tapering or stopping to buy at this particular moment,
or creating money and creating dollars to basically continue this process,
the reality is if things go south,
there's,
there's no limitation on let's just create another few trillion.
There was no limitation on,
on literally any of the process.
And so talking about assets,
hard assets or crypto currencies as a way to,
um,
yeah,
just,
just infuse a limitation to the system should in theory be able to reduce the
volatility of the system.
Now,
on any given day,
there's,
you know,
the market's moving for different reasons.
You know,
geopolitics,
wars trading or trade wars,
whatever.
But,
but in terms of the overall backdrop of the system,
if you have something that's real,
that's,
that's there as a peg or even a proportional,
a proportion of all the currency activity in the world,
the idea is that it should reduce the risk.
It's like any portfolio,
portfolio,
finance,
it's like if you have more,
the idea is if you're diversified you,
you reduced the risk.
Now in practice you'd have to watch what's going on.
Um,
but if you have a standard of some sort outside of the system that's limited,
that should reduce the volatility ultimately of the system.
And it should act as a sort of counterbalance to the unlimitedness of what these
people are doing.
Because not only are they not limited in terms of how much money or currency can
be creative and they're not limited in terms of what they have to show in terms
of where it went or what happens if it goes away or what happens if anything
gets really negative.
There's no real auditing going on.
There's,
there's no real checks and balances to,
to any of this.
Whereas an outside hard asset could be a check and balance.
The Chinese
currency is that the,
was the IMF uses,
what does,
does that have that same kind of effect of sort of stabilize the volatility and
what effect does that have for China?
Like is it a good thing for them or is it like problematic if a bunch of their
currency gets created to deal with some financial crisis?
Right.
It is a good question.
It hasn't had yet the kind of effect in terms of the percentage of trade that is
done in Chinese currency at this particular moment relative to the percentage
they have of the basket is still low.
So they basically came into this basket between the UK pound,
the Japanese yen and then sort of the year on the dollar.
So they kind of came in between third and fourth place.
So Japan and China kind of have a,
you know,
sort of,
the,
the mix and mash of what place there.
And in terms of third and fourth,
but they kind of came in pretty high.
Um,
but the actual trade that goes on internationally,
um,
and the Chinese run still remains pretty low just because it takes time to catch
up.
So they came in high because of the size of their economy.
But in terms of the actual tray that's going on,
there's still,
um,
that number is still small but going up.
And the reason for that is they are very active in creating trade partnerships
and currency relationships,
um,
that involve the red.
And in fact,
the u s banks have opened just in the last few months.
I'm the major banks like JP Morgan Chase and stuff has opened clearing banks or
banks that can actually take Chinese currency for the purpose of getting
involved in the Chinese market.
So I think that's going to grow.
Um,
I don't the second part of your question again.
Yeah.
What,
what right.
Just asking.
So
it gives them a political seat at the table too.
I,
one of the reasons that they a and geopolitical,
uh,
state at the table,
one of the reasons they want it to match,
um,
their status in the sort of ladder of,
of,
of the world and,
and sort of the entities that run things,
um,
from a,
from a monetary standpoint is because it helps their economic superpower status.
It helps their relationships with other countries in the region in,
um,
throughout the world.
Um,
and so that's one of the reasons it's beneficial to them.
It's sort of like,
look,
if this is,
if this is the basket that's representing the world and we're actually bigger
than several of these economies,
then why shouldn't we be in it?
Because once we were in it,
then we can utilize that to,
to develop our sort of presence elsewhere.
And what they've done with some of the money that they've been fabricating as
well,
um,
is they've used it specifically for that purpose of having like better
relationships and alliances with countries saying like,
you know,
you,
you give us your workers and we'll build this bridge and we'll finance it.
Um,
and so a lot of the money that they've created is actually gone outside of
China,
but for development projects and,
and that's their way.
That's their strategy of developing a long term,
um,
economic presence and a super power presence by having,
you know,
like when I like the beginning video,
they,
I'm in,
I'm in Colombo,
Sri Lanka.
Um,
in the,
in the first scene of that video,
um,
and,
and in the middle of Colombo,
there's,
there's a huge tower and it's,
it's reminiscent of the Shanghai Tower,
which is like the second tallest building in the world.
And,
and I looked,
it was like a mini version and you know,
and even when you,
when you would go,
right,
even when you're studying this,
you're not,
you're not following every like real estate development in the world.
And so I'm in the middle of Columbia and I'm like,
oh,
that looks,
that looks a lot like the Shanghai Tower.
That's kind of cool.
And of course it turns out that was a Chinese funded it.
Um,
they had their engineers come over and do it.
It was a joint effort also with people in Sri Lanka.
But the basically,
um,
that's how the presence develops.
It's like the boots on the ground,
the military,
it's like,
you know,
structures on the ground.
So I guess I'm still trying to wrap my head around run all of this.
Right.
And,
and still trying to better understand that the check and balance.
So,
so,
so my understand is when we're looking at this,
right?
Like the reason why we haven't seen any crash or fall is because all of the
players are recognizing each other's currencies,
right?
Like they're,
they're recognizing that they're printing,
they're playing along.
And is,
is this crash out,
you know,
could possibly happen is does that happen when someone says,
no,
we don't,
you know,
recognize that the money that you've been printing or the money,
but you've been trading back and forth is,
is not admissible anymore.
We're not going to take in,
is that when you know,
everything crashes because otherwise it's just based on the strength of an
economy.
Yeah.
Right,
right.
And what stops and that,
that's kind of the odd thing that's been happening over the last 10 years.
All of this started out as an emergency policy 10 years ago.
Um,
and,
and obviously the fact that it still exists as an indication that whatever
caused that emergency hasn't really been fixed.
And if you pulled the plug,
yes,
it'll be a problem.
So whether you pull the plug on,
I'm working with someone else's car and see which of these banks can't really do
when they own nature,
they trade in each other's cards.
So they own each other's car and see they,
they hold bonds in each other's currency.
Um,
particularly the holding of the dollar because we have the most amount of debt
relative to the rest of,
of,
of their,
their nations.
And,
and so the problem is,
um,
if,
if you,
if they stop that,
that's one way the system could collapse if they stopped because they don't
trust each other.
It's because this happens again.
It's because you all of a sudden have a bunch of banks going under or,
or having a real
crisis of some sort that's,
you know,
related to a derivative.
It's related to a derivatives that have,
are now partly created from corporate bonds that used to be mortgage bonds.
And those corporate bonds start to default.
So those derivative start to go under,
the whole chain starts to happen again.
And they're like,
well,
wait a minute,
we really need to accelerate our sort of move away from these currencies are
from each other.
That is a car.
That is how these crises happen.
It's not like this definitive statement like Europe cancer.
We're never going to use a dollar like that.
Just,
it's just not going to happen.
But what they can do is they can develop sort of relationships outside a little
dollar so that if something like this happens again and the chances are it will
start in the United States again to,
um,
because we have went a lot of money to a lot of countries.
We've done all the complex structures,
we have sort of more at risk,
um,
and when more codependent in general related related to the world and other
countries are,
um,
then then you could have that,
that false start to happen.
So it's not like a decision,
um,
we're not going to trust your currency.
It's more like we're not going to trust the way you deal with your system and
what,
what happened in,
in the developing countries,
um,
in the wake of the financial crisis is there,
there's,
um,
and I talk about this in the book,
there's a lot more meetings.
There's a lot more conferences amongst themselves.
There's a lot more growth and trade agreements outside of the u s and like not
necessarily using Japan.
And then there's ones where Japan's using Europe.
There's just a lot of realignments going on.
And that's a way to say not so much we won't use it at all or we won't use your
currency.
But we are cognizant that like this is still on kind of shaky ground.
And so the next time there is a financial crisis,
hopefully we have a little bit more protection.
All sorts of alternatives,
which may or may not.
How I,
it depends what happens.
It depends how big that is.
I mean,
no one really expected the market to be cut by like 45% in 2008 from where it
was the year before.
I mean,
it wasn't an expectation.
Um,
and even now when I say this stuff like the,
the market is going to potentially crash.
You know,
we're up with these like heady heights.
Most people don't feel the same way,
but it could still happen.
Maybe it's like a novice question,
but then couldn't,
couldn't everyone just hit the reset button and then below each other back up
again?
Okay.
Well,
one of the solutions or
possible paths that I talk about in,
in the last chapter,
um,
is this sort of idea of cancelling out each others debt,
and doing it in such a way that,
that,
that the countries that are most,
that would be most burdened by a collapse that are most burdened by a collapse
that they did not cause in 2008,
um,
could be in a more stable situation.
What's happened with all of this is that the countries that were sort of most of
the,
at the center of the last financial crisis and have the ability to do more harm
financially are the ones that got the most subsidies.
And so that just created,
you know,
sort of more inherent risk.
And again,
I could go on for you and this can go on for a long time,
but it created more on heroin.
So,
so that's one of the things that,
that that could also,
so the word collusion to me anyway,
has kind of a negative connotation.
Would you,
is it fair to characterize this collusion in your view as something sinister or
do these people responsible for these systems think they're acting sort of in a
very honorable way,
saving
the economy or whatever?
Well,
it's weird because,
I mean I,
I think,
I think most of them believes that that what they're doing is,
is
okay
ultimately going to help the economy.
Even though the evidence is that it hasn't,
the evidence is that wage growth hasn't really increased.
Dot growth has increased.
So certain bonuses have increased.
But,
but the evidence is that the economies that supposedly were fixed,
our are really sputtering and the economy is a,
didn't receive so much quantitative easing or other doing better or they're,
they're still sort of caught up in what might be the impact of a,
of what happens here.
So it's,
it's,
um,
it's hard to say.
Um,
but,
um,
I,
I think what ultimately will will happen though is,
is that at some point these people,
they shift.
Like some of them move out in some new people come in.
Um,
Mario Draghi at some point has to leave and,
um,
probably or possibly,
but probably the,
um,
whoever takes his place will come say from Germany or from a country that
actually is against this policy and actually would prefer that,
that less artificial money is in the system.
Um,
and they have political reasons for that.
The economy is doing better than some of the other condoms in Europe.
So this,
this goes to this head,
all the ramifications.
And so a shifting in the actual individuals,
um,
at the top of these institutions could create a shift in the policy.
Um,
but also there's a way to unwind this or at least to start turn wine that
actually is using this kind of off the rails solution.
And in a good way,
like for example,
the Fed could take,
um,
a trillion or a 2 trillion or whatever,
they're four and a half trillion worth of money they created and assets they
received in return for doing that,
um,
and create an infrastructure bank or create a development bank or do something
that's actually,
um,
really financing the,
the real economy and also sort of moving forward.
Um,
when I was in China,
I took the high speed rail from,
from Beijing to Shanghai.
Um,
and it's,
it's this,
I don't know if anyone has,
I mean it's,
it's just,
uh,
I mean,
when you talk hive,
it's really fast.
Like you cannot see the countryside.
Like it is just yours and it's,
and it's quiet and it's,
I mean,
it's,
it's excellent technology.
I mean,
obviously it costs what it costs,
but I mean,
that's the kind of development that's the kind of infrastructure building.
Um,
you know,
developing the technology in conjunction with a sort of real,
um,
real,
uh,
parts of the economy that,
that real people actually work on it.
That's fine.
That's more forward stabilizing.
So you could actually take a lot of the money that's been created and rather
than have it go into debt and have it go into stock,
actually haven't diverted.
Um,
nobody's going to be happy about that.
It might cause a correction,
but ultimately it's a question of long term versus short term.
Thank you so much.
Yeah,
no,
thank you.
Thank you.
[inaudible].